la maison de Coville de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux comme neuve
totalement transformé l'espace culturel
à ouvert ses portes ce week-end pour une
inauguration en 100 et lumière une
entrée redessinée un lieu inondé de
lumière et des accès que tous peuvent
emprunter tel est le nouveau visage du
centre culturel de Voisins-le-Bretonneux
avant l'escalier ne permettait pas tout
le monde de pouvoir accéder aux salles
d'exposition c'est une maison je pense
plus accueillante et une maison qui
permettra d'avoir du spectacle vivant
avec ce grand parvis que nous avons fait
devant la maison les architectes Roberto
siriani et Fabien Duchesne ont pensé
modernité tout en conservant l'âme et la
mémoire d'une bâtisse historique comme
toutes les vieilles maisons il y a
beaucoup de massivité c'est des beaux
produits des beaux matériaux mais on a
du mal à faire fonctionner et programme
contemporain on a vu un magnifique place
devant on a vu qu'il y avait quelques
arbres à l'arrière et on s'est dit bon
quelque chose à jouer entre devant
derrière et on s'est dit aussi que cette
maison
on circuit les mal autour donc on a
failli sur un jardin et donc du coup
elle est devenue une espèce de
d'éléments un peu central le cœur du
bâtiment a été détruit pour laisser
place à la lumière et la transparence
les gens se voient les uns avec les
autres et donc du coup ils visualise
mieux un espace en fait on peut très
bien voir quelqu'un avec qui on est
rentré qui a un état différent et c'est
ce qu'on cherchait modernisation mise
aux normes de sécurité création d'un
ascenseur mais aussi là je
supplémentaire en sous-sol bureau et
logo associatif la nouvelle maison de
Coville était une priorité pour la
municipalité qui a pris en charge la
moitié du coût des travaux dont le total
s'élève à un million 400.000 euros